- You know, Chelsea and I did
a series about gutsy women.
It's called "Gutsy."
It's going to premiere in
September on AppleTV plus.
And we interviewed women
comics, and we did that in part,
because you know some people still say,
women can't be funny.
And frankly, I disagree--
- Oh, Marsha Warfield?
- --completely! Are you kidding?
And you know, and we
interviewed Wanda Sykes,
who was telling us--
- [Kelly] I love her.
- --who I adore. We interviewed her,
and she was telling us
about how she'd gone to
a big comedy event that was
to raise money for cancer.
- [Kelly] For cancer.
- So, I mean, it was a charitable event,
but she and a bunch of
comics were doing it.
And she was the only woman.
And they were in Boston, I think.
And she had some jokes about politicians
who shall remain nameless.
And so she had these jokes,
half the audience laughed
and half the audience booed
But the other men who'd been on the stage,
had also had political jokes.
- Yeah.
- And people either
laughed or they didn't,
but they didn't boo. And Wanda
was saying like, you know,
"Here I am, right. I'm out
there. I'm telling these jokes.
And I'm a woman telling these jokes.
And somehow that produces the boo's."
I thought that was really interesting.
- And for your daughter, that's my thing.
Like for my daughter,
for your kids, your kids,
like it's, I want a better world.
I don't want women to
have to keep dancing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I don't want to dance around it.
- You know, the female soccer
team! Female soccer team.
- [Kelly] You should be able to be bold,
and courageous, and funny!
- [Hillary] Yes. They're
much better than our men.
- I say we get them their money!
- Yes. Give them their money.
(audience cheers)
(Hillary laughs)
Give them their money!